[Música]
raul
isso sim é realizar o sonho e é
justamente sobre isso que eu vim falar
que hoje como um sonho pode mudar a
minha vida ea vida de meus alunos sobre
nuno martins professor e pesquisador do
instituto federal goiano campus
hidrolândia e coordenador do meia núcleo
de estudos em agroecologia formado por
alunos e agricultores e pesquisadores
certa vez diante de uma parte chata da
vida tive um sonho um sonho que moldou o
meu futuro
sonhei que estava à mesa diante de
várias pessoas iluminadas adiantes umas
com óculos outras bar dúvidas de que me
diziam que eu deveria dedicar meu tempo
em ajudar as pessoas a ajudar as pessoas
que vivem inseridas num ambiente no
ambiente que precisa levar em
consideração as necessidades das
gerações futuras que eu deveria dedicar
meu tempo em ajudar essas pessoas e que
deveria parar de perder o meu tempo com
as mesquinharias da vida com as
futilidades humanas como rancor e ódio e
inveja egoísmo como ciúmes do bloco né
foi um um apê pegou bem no queixo
foi bem no queixo me fez levantar o que
me fez levantar me fez olhar o mundo com
outros olhos com outra direção
tinha que acordar tinha que mexer e doeu
do euro
doeu porque mudar as crenças mudar a
forma de ver o mundo sair daquela visão
egoísta por um paradigma ecológico onde
tudo está relacionado onde tudo está
interligado acreditar que todos nós
seres humanos microorganismos recursos
naturais finitos ou não renováveis ou
não estamos todos dentro do mesmo
organismo chamado planeta terra
mas eu mesmo tendo tentado manter essa
visão sistêmica como ser humano que sou
reclamava e esse meu trabalho
reclamava do meu trabalho reclamava da
estrada que me leva ao trabalho
reclamava por esse trabalho está na zona
rural
reclamava dos bichinhos dos insetos das
cobras que apareciam de vez em quando no
nosso dia a dia é mais uma das
atividades onde vamos aos agricultores
vivenciar o seu dia a dia e decide vence
ao seu cotidiano
eu tive a oportunidade tive a
oportunidade de enxergar que meu sonho
poderia se tornar realidade e que aquela
realidade poderia se tornar o meu sonho
tive a oportunidade de conhecer a
agrofloresta a agrofloresta um sistema
de produção de alimentos onde cada
espécie tem sua função dentro daquele
sistema ou de cada espécie ocupa um
espaço e um tempo dentro daqueles
no espaço um sistema com infinitas
possibilidades de pesquisa de
desenvolvimento
fiquei louco fiquei louco naquela
actividade naquele momento eu comecei a
refletir e vi uma atividade ministrada
por um agricultor agroflorestal que se
tornou um grande amigo
naquele momento pude perceber que eu
reclamava de barriga cheia
reclamava de barriga cheia até mesmo
porque todas as pessoas que procuravam
aqueles ensinamentos que procuravam
aquelas atividades que iam a esse tipo
de de curso para aprender sobre a água
floresta 90% das pessoas estavam ali
fugindo das doenças da cidade não eram
agricultores que eu passei a manhã
imaginava mas eram pessoas fugindo da
cidade das doenças da cidade da poluição
do barulho do agito da violência da
pressão da depressão de tudo aquilo que
a cidade pode nos oferecer e que estavam
indo pra colocar a mão na terra para ter
contato com a natureza para namorar a
natureza aprender a cultivar os próprios
alimentos alimentos esses exemplos de
produtos que pode ser prejudicial
prejudicar a nossa saúde produtos estão
sendo liberados lá fora que são
proibidos lá fora estão sendo liberados
aqui dentro pois é outro o outro o outro
cruzado outros o cão bem no queixo que
me fez até mudar de direção me fez mudar
de direção me fez ver que eu tinha tudo
aquilo que aquelas pessoas procuravam
aquilo estava lá meu alcance eu
precisava agir precisava mexer precisa
fazer alguma coisa eu estava lá no meio
do cerrado no meio da natureza corre
corre pela instituição para mostrar as
pessoas pra falar pra elas o tanto que
aquela água floresta de um potencial de
pesquisa de desenvolvimento daquelas
pesquisas poderiam gerar subsídios que
os agricultores agroflorestais e não só
eles
aquelas pessoas que estão em fase de
transição para uma agricultura mais
sustentável e sabe que a crise de serra
que aquilo ali plantado daquele jeito
aquelas árvores adensadas aquela coisa
tudo ali um amontoado no outro era uma
bagunça uma balbúrdia um balde de água
fria também sokhan bem no meio da áres
dessa vez mostra o vídeo nosso vídeo
esses ocorram esses o cão
doeu do euro está doendo até hoje
doeu doeu porque não adiantava ficar
chorando não adianta ficar lamentando eu
tinha que mexer eu tinha que agir
eu tinha que me movimentar tinha que ser
resiliente como a natureza
tinha que aprender a me recuperar a
pegar aquela empolgação lado o início e
pra isso eu tive uma super inspiração
uma inspiração que partiu da minha casa
uma inspiração que partiu das gerações
futuras
seu filho o seu filho é a geração futura
e meu filho que me deu esse desenho de
presente
hoje eu peguei lá no meu o meu trabalho
me inspirava todo dia tentando olhar
para aquele desenho e aprender realmente
o que aquela natureza tinha que me
ensinar tinha me ensinar a ser
resiliente acreditar no potencial e
depois de várias tentativas depois de
várias negativas
tivemos enfim um projeto aprovado com
recurso financeiro para executar para
realizar a missão do néia a socialização
e construção de conhecimentos
relacionados à agroecologia e produção
sustentável integrando as atividades de
ensino de pesquisa e de extensão na
atividade de ensino compartilhávamos a
comunidade acadêmica através de aulas
roda de conversa oficinas palestras um
pouco dessa visão sistêmica um pouco do
do que é o desenvolvimento sustentável a
importância de se considerar as pessoas
de se considerar ao ambiente o meio
ambiente o desenvolvimento da economia
compartilhamos políticas públicas
compartilhamos informações metodologias
mas não ficamos só na teoria
levávamos eles a prática
levamos eles para o campo levávamos os
alunos para o campo para colocar a mão
na massa e aprender com os problemas
reais a colocar a mão na massa e pensar
agir de verdade sair da caixinha sair da
casinha sair da sala de aula sair dessa
educação formal por uma educação real e
com isso aprendemos a namorar natureza e
transformamos essa área
um grande experimento numa grande
projeto de pesquisa
transformamos essa área num sistema
agroflorestal experimental conhecido
como seif
félix esse experimento contou com a
colaboração de um viveiro que doou as
mudas de uma construtora que doou o
sistema de irrigação e de forma
participativa de forma coletiva
transformamos aquela área num super
laboratório vivo onde são realizadas
várias aulas práticas de diversas
disciplinas da instituição é objeto de
pesquisa de vários projetos é o ambiente
para várias atividades de extensão e
transferência de tecnologia construção
de conhecimentos
há um ano e meio temos acompanhar o
desenvolvimento dessas plantas
envolvendo os alunos tentando buscar
respostas para a influência do homem
nesse sistema que pode influenciar com
as rodas o que ele pode influenciar
mantendo a cobertura vegetal morta sobre
aquele solo imitando se inspirando na
natureza
então temos acompanhado a altura das
plantas
o diâmetro das plantas
as características daquele microclima
temperatura do solo umidade relativa
temperatura do ar velocidade doha e
transformamos aquela área
um experimento de longa duração uma
pesquisa dinâmica uma agrofloresta
funcional
o experimento com três tratamentos em
triple kata que a cada ano teremos uma
resposta diferente teremos muita
natureza para namorar
e não é só isso nas atividades de
extensão não só levamos aos agricultores
para o nosso ambiente de trabalho para
compartilhar seus conhecimentos para
socializar as suas dificuldades para nos
inspirar e nas pesquisas científicas
mas não só levamos eles até nossa escola
mas também vamos até eles
vamos lá aprender o dia a dia deles com
quem sabe aprenderam no cotidiano ver as
dificuldades reais resolver os problemas
reais aprender com quem tá ali colocando
a mão na massa e aprendendo produzindo
alimentos de verdade alimentos saudáveis
nessas atividades
nós aprendemos que a natureza que essa
nessa economia está inserida no meio
ambiente
no meio ambiente rico em sócio e
biodiversidade e que esses fatores devem
ser levados em consideração os processos
educacionais que os desenvolvimentos
pensando nas necessidades das gerações
futuras e todas aquelas pessoas que
estão ali todas aquelas pessoas que
estão ali estão buscando qualidade de
vida inclusive aquele pequeno ele lembra
do meu filho aquele que desenhou naquela
época tinha três anos
esse curso foi esse ano já com seis anos
ele acompanha ele me inspira me inspira
ali do meu lado e você acha que vocês
acham que ele ficou só olhando só
observando até tu não colocamos a mão na
massa aprendemos ao longo de três dias
acampado numa agrofloresta tivemos a
oportunidade de construir conhecimento
juntos e esse
essa é uma grande lição da agrofloresta
trabalharmos juntos trabalharmos de mãos
dadas
de mãos dadas nós conseguiremos
transformar realidades transformar
atividades exaustivas em momentos de
construção e socialização de
conhecimentos conseguiremos juntos
realizar sonhos
eu sempre conto os meus alunos a
história de um rapaz que ao voltar da
escola
caminhava pela beira da praia e abaixava
pegava na estrela do mar e jogados de
volta para o mar chegava a outra
estrelinha do mar
jogava de volta para o mar
vendo aquilo ali um homem indignado
chegou nele falou o rapaz você não vê
que está perdendo seu tempo olha quantas
estrelas do marketing aqui você não vai
conseguir salvar todas
o rapazinho pegou mais uma estrelinha
olhou bem na cara daquele moço e falou
essa aqui eu vou salvar e isso é a
agroecologia isso é a agrofloresta se
fizermos o nosso papel se trabalharmos
juntos conseguiremos realizar sonhos
conseguiremos transformar realidades
conseguiremos promover saúde com
alimentos saudáveis conseguiremos
promover inclusão social levando aqueles
agricultores encurtando a cadeia de
comercialização levando eles marca mais
próxima dos consumidores
esse é um caminho sem volta
nós produtores consumidores e estamos
vivenciando isso em todo o mundo e esses
são os primeiros frutos do nosso
trabalho da nossa pesquisa frutos que
estão só no início muita sementinhas
estão sendo plantadas e muitas vidas vão
ser transformadas e muitos sonhos serão
realizados
essa é a floresta
esse é nosso experimento essa esse é meu
trabalho e esse é um sonho realizado
gratidão observa
[Aplausos]